if you want to make real progress you
have to challenge yourself to rethink
what you consider impossible
the expression like talking to a wall
means that the person you're talking to
can't or won't listen
because walls can't listen
or can they
it's exactly this kind of accepted
wisdom that we love debunking
if you have ingenuity and determination
then really nothing's impossible
we're going to be conducting our
experiment at the berlin wall memorial
it's the only section where both sides
of the wall are still standing with no
man's land in between
to get the wall to listen we're going to
use something called an accelerometer
we normally use these accelerometers to
pick up microscopic vibrations inside
machines like turbines and jet engines
they help us diagnose potential problems
before they arise so that we can prevent
power outages and flight delays
we're going to attach an accelerometer
to one side of the wall if we're right
it should be sensitive enough to detect
the tiny vibrations produced by a person
talking on the other side
we'll be filtering this signal and then
playing it through speakers to a group
of kids on the far side
so in a way the kids will be listening
to what the wall is hearing
we won't have someone just talking to a
wall he'll be reading a whole story book
let's see if it works
the cat's tail
the cat's tail
will land far away but also right near
the two groups of cats
oh didn't you hear
did i say they were the same
not quite there was one difference
although very slight
so now let me tell you just how to win
perhaps building the ditch and got
hitters of water and lived forever in
peace
just as they ought
you